[Música]
'twitter va a proteger a los usuarios
que colaboren con la verificación de
noticias falsas a través de su programa
bear watch un programa en el que los
usuarios pueden comprobar la veracidad
de la información que se encuentra en
esta red social antes era necesario que
los usuarios enlazarán su cuenta de ver
whats con un perfil de twitter de forma
pública cosa que generaba que no muchas
personas se animarán entonces a
contribuir con la verificación pero la
compañía anuncio que tomó medidas para
así proteger la identidad de estos
colaboradores para ello quiero saludar
entonces a jan freddy gutiérrez él es el
director de colchane gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 hablemos entonces de estas
noticias falsas que circulan por todas
las redes sociales por todo internet en
este noviembre sobre todo de lesiones en
américa latina' tuvimos elecciones en
argentina tuvimos las primarias en chile
también en venezuela el domingo tenemos
las elecciones en honduras las
presidenciales cómo afecta esto el voto
cómo afecta esto a nuestra sociedad
muy bueno si es bueno es importante
ahora que estamos en un medio de
comunicación que señalemos que aunque es
muy popular el término facebook news
noticias falsas los verificadores
preferimos hablar de desinformación la
desinformación además no sólo es este
contenido viral que parece ser noticioso
o que tiene un formato que simula ser de
medios de comunicación sino también hay
mucho el contenido viral que por tener
en forma de vídeos audios de whatsapp o
memes pueden confundir por el forma o
cuál es la consecuencia bueno
lamentablemente lo hemos visto en el
plebiscito de la paz en colombia lo
hemos visto en el praxis y lo viven en
distintas elecciones muchos ciudadanos
que consumen están expuestos a la
desinformación sienten que no vale la
pena participar
porque en la desinformación finalmente
trata de desacreditar las instituciones
desacreditar la democracia y siempre
abona el voto político o antisistema en
freddie esta desinformación también
afecta a nuestra salud hablamos en el
contexto mundial de la pandemia de kobe
19 cuánta desinformación entonces ha
circulado en las redes sociales en torno
a las vacunas para combatir esta
enfermedad cómo nos afecta además la
desinformación a la salud qué tan grave
es este problema de desinformación que
vivimos en la actualidad con esta
masificación de las redes sociales la
masificación del internet
es gravísimo es una bola que incluso
supera los esfuerzos de las 300 unidades
de fax equipo de verificación que
existen en el mundo 50 medios
latinoamericanos nos unimos para una
campaña unidad llamada delatan chequea
vacunas para compartir contenidos y aún
así nos superan pero te quiero citar un
estudio que se hizo en eeuu en la
universidad de chicago que encontró que
los distritos donde la gente
estuvo más expuesta a programas de
televisión que negaron la gravedad del
cob y tienen más afectados más
contagiados más muertes y aquellos
distritos donde la gente se informó
correctamente es decir la desinformación
puede matar
como jhon freddy ustedes hacen este fast
track como pueden combatir ustedes la
desinformación qué tan difícil además
puede llegar a ser
bueno el check in goal a verificación de
hechos y datos tiene una metodología muy
específica para consultar
estadísticas datos estudios académicos y
expertos que nos lleven a comprobarlo a
demostrar algo que no es tan usual en el
periodismo que un contenido es engañoso
o tu esa falta de contexto o simplemente
falsa es una invención y esta
metodología está certificada por una red
internacional de verificadores y además
por contralores externos académicos que
nos revisan una vez al año que cumplimos
con todos los pasos periodísticos pero
además con compromisos éticos y ley de
transparencia y que tan difícil puede
ser hay verificaciones que pueden salir
en seis horas pero nos hemos tomado
incluso hasta dos meses para hacer
revisión de 360 grados de vídeos de
revisión de meta análisis y por supuesto
la pandemia nos sometió a algo que era
tan novedoso que la información
científica cambiaba
semana incluso cada día los
pronunciamientos de la ms y al mismo
tiempo
sometió a los periodistas al por nada un
trabajo excesivo que muchas veces lo
superó emocionalmente ya freí a más
maternos con un ejemplo y un tema
bastante espinoso con la cuenta de
twitter del ex presidente de eeuu donald
trump que recordemos el twitter
suspendió su cuenta en esta red social
por decir que desinformaba
qué opinión le merece a esto que se
tiene que hacer con un personaje tan
influyente perdón que que le complete la
pregunta
pues este es un gran debate y que creo
que es importante además diferenciar lo
que hacemos nosotros de la verificación
que es brindar mejor información para
que cuando alguien esté expuesto un
contenido que ha sido verificado puede
haber una etiqueta y pueda realizar la
verificación y ello es algo distinto a
las normas comunitarias de las
plataformas que son las que deciden
borrar o restringir o suspender a
alguien es algo muy distinto porque las
normas comentarios no están tan claras
no sabemos exactamente cómo funcionan
estas decisiones a lo interno de las
plataformas tecnológicas y creo que este
es el mayor debate porque mucha gente se
pregunta por qué lo hicieron al
presidente eeuu por qué no lo hicieron
antes porque lo están haciendo en
algunos países y algunos países no un
tweet de álvaro uribe vélez fue borrado
en colombia también tweets de nicolás
maduro pero no sé y parece que no es
igualitario la decisión de borrar o
restringir cuentas si estás en el
gobierno si estás en la oposición y eso
creo que es el gran debate sobre si las
normas comunes es pudiesen estar
violando la libertad de expresión no
solo de los líderes políticos sino de
sus seguidores mi opinión es que esto es
realmente es muy peligroso por la falta
de transparencia no sabemos cómo se
toman estas decisiones y además no hay
una contraloría completa de los
periodistas de la sociedad civil para
saber cómo están actuando las
plataformas tecnológicas muy brevemente
una recomendación para la gente que nos
ve a esta hora que recomendación les da
para combatir esta desinformación
siempre le pueda decir que hay que
examinar nuestros propios sesgos
emocionales y psicológicos normalmente
decimos que no nos gusta la
desinformación que detectamos la
facebook news que no caemos en ella pero
justamente hay que ver cuáles son los
sextos de confirmación los ojos de
autoridad que hacen que algunas noticias
nos parezcan más creíbles y otras
esta reacción negativa que solemos tener
cuando nos exponemos almarcha equihua la
verificación y nos dicen que algo es
falso si sentimos que aún podría ser
verdadero entonces tenemos que revisar
que la desinformación siempre nos va a
tocar una tecla una sensibilidad y eso
nos expone y nos hace vulnerables nadie
está libre de caer en una desinformación